good morning Hank it is Monday November
1st which too many nerdfighters is the
beginning of NaNoWriMo National Novel
Writing Month in which thousands of
people write a novel in a single month
fair by making me very jealous of them I
am NOT doing NaNoWriMo this year but I
am doing nap bag toy bins calm national
finish a draft of your book I mean
seriously come on month
seriously Green come on ok so often when
we try to learn about something with
nerdfighteria whether it's like quarks
or like The Catcher in the Rye we see
comments in which people are like oh I
wish you were my chemistry teacher or
you would make a great English teacher
and I'm always really flattered by that
but unfortunately it's completely untrue
because there's this huge gulf between
that which is informational and that
which is actually educational consider
the lemming is a good name for a band so
Hank you know about lemmings they were
turned into a series of fantastic
computer games lemmings are tiny little
buttons that live in Gig well not so
close please better right so lemmings
are tiny rodents that live in the Arctic
and the one thing we all know about
lemmings is that when their population
gets too big lemmings like to commit
mass suicide by jumping off of cliffs
we've known this for a long time Sigmund
Freud referenced it in a lot of his work
and in fact you can see lemmings commit
mass suicide if you watch the 1958
Academy award-winning documentary white
wilderness made by the Disney Company
it's a very famous documentary Hank yeah
mostly famous for staging lemming
suicide well yes yes that technically
true lemmings are not suicidal they're
just stupid and sometimes when stupid
animals go running they run over cliffs
but for this documentary white
wilderness the creators really wanted to
have footage of lemmings committing
suicide and they couldn't find any
footage of it because lemmings don't
commit suicide so what they did was they
got a bunch of lemmings they shipped
them across Canada and then they forced
them to commit suicide I think that
story raises a lot of interesting
questions including if you are forced to
commit suicide did you commit suicide
and to what extent can we rely on film
and video documentaries to be factual
and how can we as viewers constantly
stay mindful of all the events that are
happening outside the frame oh I know I
just boat tank I'm a dancer and to
discuss those questions with any
complexity would of course be necessary
to read Susan Sontag brilliant book
regarding the pain of others and much of
other stuff that we can't talk about in
four minutes so the fact that the Walt
Disney Company staged the suicide of
lemmings is an interesting fact and it's
in
formational but it's not ultimately
educational and that's one of the
problems at least so far with the
internet the internet is really really
good at providing information it is
proven less good at providing education
so Hank your song about quarks is a
wonderful wonderful song and it helps we
don't understand some things about
quarks but it doesn't give me the entire
context that I need in order to
understand you know particle physics the
problem with being a teacher is that you
have to teach not only the interesting
stuff but the context for the
interesting stuff which is often
incredibly boring
like I can tell you that a very
significant event in the French
Revolution occurred in an indoor tennis
court and I can tell you that Marie
Antoinette wanted to have fancy last
words but her actual last words were sir
I beg your pardon after she stepped on
her executioner's foot and I can tell
you that John Jacques Rousseau whose
political philosophy so deeply
influenced the French Revolution like to
be spanked by girls so much that he
would sometimes drop his drawers in
public in the hopes that they would
smack him in a related story ineffective
strategy is ineffective but knowing all
of those facts would not actually lead
to you having an informed understanding
of the French Revolution well I think
we've gotten pretty good at
informational ism I don't think that
we've gotten very educational yet but
that's about to change
Hank beginning Friday and then
continuing all next week we are going to
make a solid effort to be educational
and nerdfighteria in this attempt we
need your help let us know what you
would like us to talk about like if
there's something in school that you
don't understand and would like to
understand or if you're done with school
is there something that you didn't learn
in school that you wish you'd learned
thank you for your suggestions thanks
for being awesome and Hank I will out
pumpkins
Hank pumpkins pumpkins pumpkins pumpkins
nerdfighters so many of you chose to
make nerd fight a stick pumpkins this
year thank you my favorite this one this
star won't go out pumpkin which reminds
me nerdfighter to get your Esther
bracelets dftba.com slash Esther 100% of
the proceeds go to this star won't go
out foundation thank you for being
awesome Hank I will see you on Wednesday